Film Courage: Shaun, if someone were to
tell you that filmmaking is a pipe dream,
what would you tell them? Shaun Paul Piccinino,
Filmmaker: I've always been a believer in
and again my parents have probably
get all the credit for this but you can
accomplish anything you set your mind to.
So there's many things that can be a pipe dream if
you let them be a pipe dream. But if it's really
in your core and your soul and your energy to
pursue being a filmmaker, I think you have to
pursue it and that's really up to you. If you
are someone who has to express yourself that way
and I also come from that mindset
and maybe it's the martial arts
but also families that never give up, never
surrender type of attitude. For me I have
pursued this business in a i think an
interesting way i i've done just about
every job you can do in filmmaking uh from hair
and makeup to you know to stunt coordination to
i've always been and i had a mentor early on in
this business who told me to diversify or die and
i've really kind of took that to heart and as
long as i was working on a film or television
show i viewed it as number one educational uh
to the ultimate goal which is you know directing
for myself um i viewed it as an education
and i was getting to be a part of something
that i love which is telling stories
uh so um i think pipe dreams are uh
only limited by your own drive um and so again
if you don't give up i believe you can make it
so a lot of the people that i have been lucky
enough to collaborate with over the years
the stories are almost the same it's they didn't
give up and all these overnight successes you
you read or hear about they're usually 10 years
20 years in the making and so it's those people
that with that drive that end up having
success on a multitude of different levels
how many people were in the town where you grew
up uh roughly like 30 to 50 000 people uh it's
is kind of the population when i was when i was
growing up it's probably more now uh but it was
also a college town so when college students were
in it it was like double and do they have a film
program there or i don't know if they have
a film there is a lot of theater so like uh
my father was a drama professor he directed two
plays a year he produced shakespeare in the park
so there's a lot of arts that way um as far as
film goes i think you can study some film at both
chico state and and butte college but i don't
know if it's a full-blown film program at least
it wasn't when i grew up there maybe they do have
something like that now so did you ever drive down
or or fly down from chico to the la area and
see what it was like here i did so i still have
family who were down in southern california
both san diego some in in los angeles so um
i did spend time and also my grandparents when
i was younger they still lived in chatsworth
so i spent time there for that and then also
i would come down for summers and visit family
i visited my family down in san diego from
probably like 14 through like 20. i would
come down every summer and stay with my aunt and
uncle um and uh so yeah so i was very familiar
with southern california it wasn't uh it wasn't a
culture shock when i moved down here in that way
there was other things that you know sure i
i wasn't expecting but uh um i at least had
some inclement in clean you know well i think uh
um moving to uh la itself i think i didn't fully
grasp what traffic meant you know even living in
san diego there's traffic but when you live live
in los angeles like really fully understanding oh
that it's five miles away but that still means an
hour in traffic you know like that i think those
kinds of things i couldn't prepare for um and uh
you know um i certainly think what i
actually thought was interesting is
sometimes los angeles might get a bad rap
like oh everybody's so rude or this or that
i think i kind of had an opposite experience
i'm like man people are actually really nice
and you know people say hello to me all the time
and you know like so almost i became a defender
of los angeles in that way i'm sure that there's
rude people everywhere and especially in traffic
that's when you get the rude people i think but uh
you know walking around the streets of of you know
everywhere i mean hollywood to to to burbank to
uh you know the valley um i've met such wonderful
people and and created such great friendships
and so i think there's a lot of uh uh misnomer
i think same thing with new york you hear that
you know that new york people might have a chip
on their shoulder or something but again if you
go there and experience it and live there i think
you you'll find a lot of great people too sure
it seems like too that you can you kind of have
a way of fitting into any environment you go in i
get that sense that you you adapt i guess that's
probably true yeah i think i am very adaptable and
i try and uh find common ground with people and i
believe that's probably a a great tool to have if
you're going to be a collaborator so myself as a
director or somebody who's capped you know being
the captain of that ship i try and lead through uh
that idea of collaboration like we're all working
together for the same goal i'm definitely not a
it's my way or the highway guy i i do have
a strong vision and i do know what i want
but i'm open to you know all the different ideas
that can make that vision even better than maybe
what i was expecting so um uh you know so i'm
very open-minded that way and i think that that
open-mindedness is what
allows me to be adaptable and
and fit in and work in different situations
and um i've just found it very useful i think
obviously uh given my parents and family credit
but also the martial arts angle of it i think
uh the philosophy of martial arts is is very
much that way studying something called tai chi
uh it is all about accepting energy and
redirecting it versus you know trying to
like you know go head on you know blunt force uh
you know trauma with something it's more about
accepting that energy redirect if it's something
negative you can let it just go right by you
um if it's something useful you can accept it and
maybe redirect it in in the way that you're um you
know approaching a problem-solving situation or
um you know being creative knowing that you had
this quote-unquote filmmaking dream and you
figured you were definitely coming to la and
this was going to be your path what were the three
obstacles the biggest obstacles that held you back
from maybe initially achieving
it or from um yeah okay i think
i think some of the biggest obstacles were maybe
just kind of coming from that maybe smaller town
mentality like it growing up becoming a filmmaker
didn't even actually seem like a plausible dream
you know uh it just wasn't even something that
i really thought about it's like oh no you got
to go to college you got to get your you know you
got to get your associate's degree you know like
it just seemed like a different path so as i
started you know when i made that leap and moved
down to southern california i didn't go right to
la and so maybe there was part of that just not
you know fully believing uh it is really
possible i think part of me was like yes
it's possible then other parts of me were like
oh that's just a you know how would you even
do that how would you even accomplish that so
i think that that kind of uh maybe self-doubt
is definitely probably one of the bigger obstacles
um i think just logistics like like figuring out
what am i gonna do when i get there like how
how are you gonna um you know just pay rent um
so that's probably some of it um and then again
education i think taking those i took uh some uh
film history classes in in college um and that
really opened my eyes and then also having a
teacher i took a creative writing class and then
discovered he also taught a script writing class
and so i ended up taking that as well so
i think some of that education also helped
me decide that yes i could you know pursue
this in it at some level um and sorry didn't
it's already interrupted but you actually
took the same class three times so the the
the history of film class that was was taught at
san marcos college down in um san diego area was
a great class so i took the first class and it
was alfred hitchcock and so we went through the
um his film history like from the very first
film he did all the way to the last film and uh
we didn't watch every film but we you know from
the different eras we he would pick a film and
we'd watch it and so we broke it down we studied
the techniques we the different things that they
you know the filmmaker would like to do
and how they interacted with actors like
the full thing it was fascinating and i loved
it and at the end of the semester i asked him
you know do you do the same filmmaker every time
he goes no every semester is different like well
who are you doing next he's uh well i'm going to
do stanley kubrick i'm like oh my god i got to
take this class again so i did i ended up taking
it three times during my time there and studied
three different filmmakers and i didn't get
credit at all on basically just auditing the class
um but i just really wanted to learn about those
filmmakers and i think that was a really great
education um and there was a different teacher
for the creative writing and script writing but
i think after getting that education
uh probably helped boost my confidence
uh and then i met and married my wife
and she was like why are we in san diego
and i had done a short film and she loved it uh
she was you know rooting in my corner she's like
this is amazing you've got to go we put in some
film festivals and did good with it but um but
it was really her saying you can do all this from
san diego but you know why not go and try you know
try it up there and so we did we moved up there
on a whim and uh the rest is history i ended up
i was doing personal training when i first moved
uh to la to to pay the bills but i got a job
really quickly in uh in um uh production being a
pa and doing all that stuff no job was ever too
small for me i was never afraid of hardware i did
extra work as well and i would i would bring a a
notebook and painted i would take notes and
i would study and try and learn like i viewed
it as an opportunity to get on set and see what
it's all about learn the terms what do they all
mean what's that person's got to be in a mark okay
what you know what's minimal focus distance mean i
literally would would try and learn every
aspect of what was going on uh and again
i felt i treated it like i was getting paid
to get an education so so i had no problem i
did i did extra work for probably nine months
ended up getting my sag card through that um
and at the same time i was personal training and
then i got the pa job on a tv show and i self
through my own little short films and things
like that in commercials i had taught myself
how to edit uh on on you know on a mac one
of the early like imovie and final cut was
first coming out and the whole adobe suites were
just starting out when i was was doing that and
so i taught myself all the all the different
little tools from photoshop to after effects
you know to editing and so i had some other skills
for my own short films and that pa job i did on a
television show of course i put on my resume i can
do final cut i can do after effects i can do that
and it wasn't even a week into that
production when they said hey we saw
you do after effects on uh on your resume like
we were under you know some crazy deadlines
do you think you could help with some rotoscoping
i'm like oh yeah i've done that before you know
so they gave me a couple shots and i did them i
turned them in they're like oh this looks really
good you think you could do some more oh sure sure
yeah no problem so i think that attitude of always
just being there ready to help ready
to work helped me excel uh through
through this business like like wildfire so one
week into being a coffee runner on this tv show
the very next so i stayed they go well do you
think you can work on a saturday and help us
no problem i'll be there showed up help did did
many different things for visual effects not just
rotoscoping i ended up compositing some pieces
i ended up doing some like lighting effects and
different things in there by that monday i was
a vfx artist on the show then one week later i
became the lead green screen effects artist on
the show so just within two weeks just because
i was ready to go i was willing to put in the work
and um just having that positive attitude and also
like we first started talking
about this being able to kind of
blend in or or fit into any situation
having that flexibility is i think what helped
me excel and that happened on other shows as well
i was a assistant stunt coordinator on a show
and literally the third day of filming i ended
up becoming the second unit director on
that show oh wow and it literally had to
do with i think perception is also being
perceptive is also a handy tool um i was
helping this the stunt coordinator helped with
casting all the stunt uh people for this show
and it was an action oriented show so we had to
choreograph and rehearse and do all these things
and i saw the executive producer pacing on like
day two back and forth frustrated and just being
you know just trying to be a nice guy just hey
are you okay you know and he starts telling me
about how they're not making their days and and
they don't know what to do and uh the director's
moving too slow and and i just threw out there
just going hey well you know the stunt coordinator
and myself we're both directors and i had
actually already directed a feature at that point
and i said if you gave us a camera we
could you know more than uh likely help you
guys film stuff and and hopefully make your day i
said whatever scenes you want to give us whatever
pieces you want to give us i know we could handle
it and the very next day he showed up with a
little like skeleton camera crew and said sean all
right you're gonna second unit direct this stuff
which at that point i got actually a little bit
terrified because i was now going over my boss's
head the stunt coordinator because like the second
unit director is almost the next step up and so
i immediately went to him like oh my gosh i told
him that you and i are both directors because we
have both directed that us as a team could help i
didn't say that i should be the director you know
and and luckily he's a great friend of mine i've
probably done the most work with him than anybody
else in this business uh noelle vega is his name a
wonderful wonderful uh friend and uh collaborator
in this business for me we've probably done over a
hundred projects together because we've worked on
video games together we've worked on stunt stuff
we he's been a producer and i've been a director
on projects uh tel entire television series we've
done together so we've really done a lot of stuff
over the years and he just he's also one of
my mentors and kind of like that big brother
uh in this industry for myself but so i was
mortified in that situation going i by no means
was trying to go over your head or try and pass
you up and uh luckily he was like i'm so busy
as the stunt coordinator he's like you go do this
you go do it and he championed me for that and and
uh it worked out well because whatever i shot was
good enough for them i guess and so then i became
the second unit director for the whole series and
then ended up fully directing several episodes as
the season went on and into season two but that's
an important lesson it sounds like because you
learn to like go to him so it didn't seem like
you were trying to go behind his back yes that's
a very stereotypical thing that happens in this
industry and people do it all the time and yeah
yeah yeah i found out well at least it's been
my experience that loyalty um in a positive
way obviously there could you know loyalty
could in certain situations maybe not be a
great thing but sure most situations is a good
thing but but for myself my personal experience
loyalty has been a very um positive uh tool um
and i've only grown from those loyalties and those
friendships and those you know i've never and i'm
just not that person as well i don't to ever you
know betray or step on somebody to get to get to
that next level i'm much more the person let's all
build ourselves up together we're stronger as a
team and you know i love the whole brat pack and
the rat packs and that whole idea like let's make
our own film family and and grow and uh and and uh
do it that way versus i'm gonna climb to the top
and step on whoever i can to get there you know
i think in some ways it's a slower process right
uh not just stepping on people and getting to
the top as fast as you can um but obviously i
think it's a more fulfilling way to do it and
i have stayed positive and happy in this
business i've been in it now 20 years
um versus feeling you know jaded or hate myself
for the things that i've done you know what i mean
uh type of thing can i ask you what was your
first job growing up like an after-school job
oh my gosh um i don't know why it's coming to
my it's like i'm seeing like you doing something
and i can't totally see what it is but i was so
busy yeah and you know i'm one of those people
who likes doing a lot of things at once like if
you give me one task it's probably way harder
for me than if you give me three tasks right
so i think uh uh my first job technically my
very first job was teaching martial arts
oh really so that's what it was and uh
kind of i would i would teach a class here and
there as a teenager as a teenager and then i went
and got a job at taco bell and i worked at taco
bell because i really wanted to save up for the
honda civic hatchback nice you know i was like 15
and a half and i started working at taco bell and
my martial arts master uh the the the head honcho
of the system the karate is a shorin rue karate
a very very traditional okinawan karate he came
through the drive-through and he saw me there and
he's like why are you working here and i go what
do you mean why am i working here i'm going i'm
saving up for this car and he goes but you could
be working at the dojo and i'm like i can he goes
yeah i'll pay you to teach classes like so i did
so i i i did work there for a little while longer
but then i i went to the to the school to the
martial arts school and i taught full-time uh for
years and years but i did have multiple jobs still
i also worked in a stereo store i also worked at a
local uh baseball like for the baseball seasons
i would go and work there so i always liked
having a lot of jobs and and then i also started
directing those commercials at that same period
um so yeah i had like three or four jobs kind
of always uh going on but uh but martial arts
i guess it was because i did teach some classes
so it's either martial art to taco bell toss-up
between the two but those were the first jobs
what a great story so he when you went to give
him his order like he's like yeah i'll have
the numbers i was working the drive-through
and then okay great did you want to have this yeah
and then and then you're like oh my gosh it's him
okay yeah well that's a great moment right yeah
it was it was pretty uh it was pretty funny and
uh and just the look on his face he's like no come
teach at the school you know so but you know what
i think working at taco bell also taught me a lot
of great lessons and sure people's skills yeah
yeah yeah it's it's uh all of those i think all
those things are important and and i have kids and
i want them to get you know they're going to
have to earn a car in the same way i did i had
to i saved up now my parents did help me with some
i think they paid for the insurance and stuff like
that on the car but um i think there was something
so fulfilling about that experience and and
earning something like that i think it was 2 700
at the time for the car wow and i that took me you
know six months at taco bell and and several more
months at teaching martial arts to save up for it
but i did and i just i loved that car i mean that
was you know because i earned it you know it's the
first like bigger item that i earned so certainly
something in the thousands of dollars you know
i'd bought saved up and bought bikes and things
like that but never um you know i think that's
part of that coming of age and you know oh yeah
all that stuff so what was the first song you
blasted through the stereos because did you get
your stereo from the stereo store of course oh
you did of course and i had a really big boom
in stereo it was ridiculous what was absolutely
of course i'm trying to think of what it would
have been at the time um i like smaller towns
have that gorgeous circles oh yeah especially
downtown chico it's definitely a cruise
that's you do a loop and we would when i
was 16 we would do the loop we would circle
several times and and thought we were very
cool uh with our ridiculous stereos um it's
a rite of passage yeah everybody's definitely
definitely it felt like uh an 80s version of
american graffiti you know it was very much that
um which is funny because i've shot several movies
in petaluma and that's american graffiti was
was shot uh some of it was shot there as well
the whole cruising the strip was shot in petaluma
oh very cool um but uh yeah i'm trying to remember
i i listen to such a variety of music i also
play music so i play guitar and bass and mess
around on the drums and stuff so i've always have
such a respect for music kind of in all genres
so i honestly i you know maybe i don't
listen to as much country but there's still
a lot of country that i really view as
amazingly you know uh artistic and talented
people performing so i will listen or maybe it's
uh you know opera maybe i'm not an opera guy
every day on my stereo but there's some
amazing music and such amazing talent that i
have respect for it so um i'm trying to think of
what everything from tom petty to oh nice to uh
it might have been a tom petty song i listened a
lot used to love the cars back then oh yeah yeah
i played a lot of that but then i'd play on
the opposite end of spectrum i would play
you know bob marley to zap and roger to frank
zappa you know like i really i really was uh i
kind of have a very broad spectrum of music that
i love eric clapton i was like obsessed with eric
clapton when i was 16. nice that's kind of that's
when i was really getting into playing the guitar
and stuff was listening to everything he did um so
okay yeah probably tom petty or something probably
free falling right okay probably blast in
and you know head out the window like ace
ventura at the time or something and the
arm too yeah oh yeah totally totally yeah
you